madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
rugby les tricolores trébuche au stade
de france
l'angleterre s'est imposée 15 à 9 pour
cette deuxième journée du tournoi des
six nations les français se disent déçus
par l'arbitrage alertait la listériose
19 départements touchés 23 cas recensés
une épidémie qui a fait sept morts dont
deux nouveaux nés l'origine est pour
l'instant inconnue jean glavany ministre
de l'agriculteur et la victime de ce
journal les vagues de protestation
contre l'extrême droite de jörg haider
plus de cent cinquante mille personnes
dans les rues de vienne diverses
manifestations en france dans les
grandes villes et à paris cinéma avec la
sortie de love me de laetitia masson
sandrine kiberlain et johnny hallyday se
partagent l'affiché de ce film qui
évoque la rencontre de deux solitudes
sans verser dans la psychose cette
alerte à la listériose suffisamment
préoccupante parce qu'elles touchent 19
départements en france et que son
origine est encore pour l'instant mal
identifié une situation prise au sérieux
par le secrétariat d'état à la santé qui
a constitué une cellule de crise et puis
ce matin jean glavany tenait une
conférence de presse pour faire état de
cette épidémie qui a donc fait sept
morts dont deux nouveau-nés d'abord le
point sur ces cas de listériose
répertoriés depuis la fin du mois de
novembre dernier jean michel carpentier
sept morts dont deux nouveaux nés pour
un total de 23 malades ayant mangé soit
de la charcuterie soit du fromage au
lait cru ou peut être encore du poisson
fumé personne n'en sait trop rien le
premier cas apparaît en novembre dernier
et ce n'est que le 2 février
trois mois plus tard le temps de faire
des analyses que les services de santé
déclenché l'alertent 23 personnes
touchées un peu partout en france dans
19 départements dans le nord l'est les
alpes avec une certaine concentration
dans la région centre également en
gironde en provence côte d'azur et dans
les pyrénées une dispersion qui pourrait
faire penser à un grand réseau de
distribution commerciale mais sans
aucune certitude
si l'on en croit les pouvoirs publics
depuis le 2 février des centaines de
fonctionnaires chercheurs contrôleur
sillonnent le pays dans la plus grande
discrétion pour trouver la ou les
entreprises à l'origine de cette
catastrophe
jusqu'à ce jour le gouvernement n'avait
rien voulu dire aux français pour éviter
une psychose générale une fuite au
ministère de l'agriculture
l' oblige ce matin a évoqué publiquement
la situation
je suis comme tout le monde c'est à dire
inquiet par par cette épidémie est
évidemment a figé par certaines de ses
conséquences et en même temps dans cette
situation extrêmement embarrassantes
pour les gouvernants et pour les
responsables qui consiste à dire nous
enquêtons mais à ce stade l'enquêté ne
nous permet pas de dire d'où vient cette
épidémie désormais un seul espoir celui
de détecter rapidement cet aliment et
son origine jean glavany évoque le
milieu de la semaine prochaine aux
alentours de mercredi mais en coulisses
au ministère on se dit je cite dans le
bleu complet avec de très vagues piste
rien de très rassurant
cette épidémie est la plus grave depuis
celle du début des années 90 qui avait
entraîné la mort de soixante trois
personnes cette fois ci les autorités
sanitaires se heurte à de nombreuses
interrogations
et c'est un véritable questionnaire qui
est menée auprès des malades pour tenter
d'identifier la bactérie
oui car c'est une forte poussée de
fièvre des frissons et des maux de tête
même les premiers symptômes d'une
listériose compliquer la tâche des
autorités médicales et sanitaires
car dans ces prémices il faut au moins
une prise de sang pour identifier la
maladie déclenchée par la listeria or si
elle est diagnostiquée à un stade
précoce
il suffit d'un traitement aux
antibiotiques pour en venir à bout c'est
d'ailleurs dans cet objectif que chaque
cas de listériose doit être désormais
signalés auprès de l'institut de veille
sanitaire
il a depuis quelques années un
dispositif de détection et dallaire de
cette épidémie extrêmement performant et
on repère aujourd'hui des épidémies qui
n'était pas détecté il ya quelques
années d'où l'impression d'une
multiplication de ces épidémies alors
que globalement l'activité
puis des mélodies de la listeria très
nettement reculé dans ce pays
l'autre difficulté tient au temps
d'incubation de la listeria jusqu'à deux
mois entre le moment où elle touche une
personne et celui où elle va provoquer
une listériose ce temps de latence rend
d'autant plus compliqué la recherche de
l'aliment à l'origine de l'infection
les trois principaux vecteurs
alimentaires sont les fromages au lait
cru
la charcuterie et les poissons fumés
mais il arrive que le chemin emprunté
par la listeria soit plus complexe comme
dans le cas présent
aujourd'hui on est dans une épidémie
sans doute un peu plus complexe parce
que il est très vraisemblable que cette
épidémie soit provoquée par un aliment
contaminé au départ mais qu'il y ait eu
ce pour l'appel des contaminations
croisées c'est à dire que partir de cet
aliment d'autres aliments pu être
contaminées en fait la listériose
s'attaque essentiellement aux sujets
dont le système immunitaire se trouvent
déjà fragilisées par la maladie par un
traitement médical de longue durée ou
dans le cas des femmes enceintes surtout
pendant la fin de la grossesse pour
cette personne là il vaut mieux se
priver des aliments à risque et surtout
ne pas hésiter à consulter son médecin
en cas de doute
chaque à venir bonsoir d'abord quelques
questions très pragmatique très
concrètes
on parle de 19 départements touchés
est-ce qu'il serait plus juste de dire
que c'est un peu partout en france que
l'épidémie s'est du sud diffuser ces
défis de 19 départements sont
effectivement répartis sur toute la
france du nord au sud du département du
nord jusqu'aux pyrénées de l'est à
l'ouest et donc on peut dire que à ce
stade c'est ce n'est que dix neuf
départements mais ils sont dans toute la
france oui effectivement
est ce que vous craignez d'autre qu'à ce
stade vous savez le réseau de veille
sanitaire dont le professeur drucker
était le directeur et le porte parole à
l'instant dans ce reportage est en
alerte depuis mars 81 18 ses terres
depuis assez peu de temps depuis deux
ans tout cas de listériose doit être
obligatoirement des cadres déclarent est
donc remonte au niveau de cet institut
de veille sanitaire solaire est très
centralisé
s'il y avait de nouveaux cas nous nous
en serions visé mais il l'épidémie a
commencé au mois de novembre
a connu un pic au mois deux dans la
deuxième quinzaine de janvier et décroît
depuis alors en effet vous dites
l'épidémie est en décembre sur quoi vous
basez pour dire cela sur les constats
sur les constats qui ne sont venues de
ses 23 cars qui se sont répartis dedans
selon une cour qui commence en novembre
qui monte jusqu'au mois de janvier qui
descendent depuis
mais ce sont des cas déclarés de malades
ou de décès alors apparemment vous avez
longtemps hésité tarder ou peut-être
choisissent d'abord de ne pas
communiquer mais pour quelles raisons
vous avez finalement donné une
conférence de presse ce matin parce que
vous ne demandiez si j'ose dire mais il
faut bien comprendre que pour pour
communiquer il faut savoir sur quoi on
communique depuis le 2 février nous
avons une alerte du réseau de veille
sanitaire
cette alerte qui consiste à dire y ait
une épidémie de listériose
à partir de ce moment que cette alerte
est déclenchée sur la base
d'informations qui remonte d'une manière
très descendre très décentralisé ses 10
ans on constate un peu partout en france
dans 19 départements 23 cas de
listériose ça remonte au niveau national
et dans ce réseau de veille sanitaire il
ya des ordinateurs si j'ose dire qu'ils
mettent en convergence existent et qui
déclenche alerte en dix ans c'est la
même souche bac bactériologie et choisit
plutôt de garder cette information est
arrivé n'aviez rien de rassurant attire
pas soit la recette exacte la sariat
rien la misère si nous communiquons
depuis le 2 février si donc si nous
avions communiqué je vous aurais dit
quoi je venais madame voilà une épidémie
ce que nous avons été contraints de dire
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils aient une
pression des médias mais pour dire voilà
à ce stade je suis incapable
les autorités sanitaires le gouvernement
c'est à dire les trois ministères qui
travaillent la main dans la main d'une
manière extrêmement solidaire c'est à
dire le secrétaire d'état à la santé les
secrétaires d'état à la consommation et
demi ça l'agriculture dans des cellules
interministériel nous nourrir nous
recherchons les causes de cette épidémie
mais à ce stade nous n'avons pas trouvé
alors peut-être une question plus
générale on a dit que paradoxalement il
n'a jamais eu si peu de cas de
listériose en même temps n'a jamais
autant communiqué ce sont les autorités
sanitaires kéké qui communiquent s
comment n'est pas dans une situation du
risque zéro c'est à dire on risque
d'entre eux d'entretenir une certaine
psychose on communique à tout va ces
appareils sont immenses ce soir c'est un
peu mon sentiment mais en même temps
c'est la société de la communication de
la transparence qui veut ça vous nous
posez des questions il faut bien qu'on
réponde et donc sans même temps il faut
dire aux français
mais que le risque zéro n'existe pas
dans la mine augmentation que vous et
moi on mange la listeria tous les jours
et que l'on mange des fromages au lait
cru on mange des charcuteries on mange
des poissons fumés et simplement le don
nous on le supporte et il ya des
catégories à risque des populations à
risque les femmes enceintes les
immunodéprimés
les personnes très âgées qui ont des
systèmes immunitaires qui sont plus
fragiles qu'il faut éduquer en leur
disant quand vous êtes dans cette
situation là il vaut mieux ne pas trop
manger de ces produits qui sont porteurs
parfois de l'histoire récente d'ouvrir
le parapluie et non des scandales en
france mais parce qu'il y aura un souci
die on a l'impression que depuis les
autorités sanitaires font tout pour ce
risque zéro et moi je me pose pas ce que
vous aurez pas appuyé par appuyer en
disant vous nous demandez de communiquer
c'est pas me demande c'est pas mon genre
d'ouvrir un piper à titre personnel je
sais je suis plutôt dans la logique
d'assumer mes responsabilités mais en
même temps il faut faire appel à
l'intelligence des français en leur
disant si vous êtes dans ce cas là c'est
assez vous êtes une population à risque
une femme enceinte et une milieu déprimé
personnes très âgées
alors essayez d'éviter de manger des bd
des fromages au lait cru des
charcuteries des pâtes et des rillettes
ou bien des dés de la charcuterie ont
gelé ou viandes et poissons fumés et si
vous avez consommé ça et que vous avez
des signes de type grippe céphalées
voire vomissements allez voir votre
médecin parce que je crois que les
recommandations de prudence qu'il faut
donner par le biais de de votre
télévision et je vous en remercie parce
qu'à ce stade nous sommes dans
l'incapacité de dire plus précisément
c'était le produit c'est tel lot nous
l'avons retirée à ce stade nous
cherchons encore merci monsieur lévi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et puis ce cas de vache folle décelé
dans dans l'ain qui porte à sept le
nombre de cas depuis le début de l'année
en france qui a été de samedi cette
vaste manifestation anti haider à vienne
sous la pluie cent cinquante mille
personnes selon la police deux cent
cinquante mille selon les organisateurs
une immense vague de protestations
contre l'extrême droite et le racisme
avec comme point d'orgue un
rassemblement place des héros face au
palais de la hofburg là même où en 38
adolf hitler il est ovationné le nouveau
chant cd wolfgang schüssel parle ce soir
d'un simple débordements émotionnels sur
place notre envoyé spécial olivier
werner en début d'après midi on pouvait
flâner dans vienne comme si de rien et
tél faire du lèche vitrine devant les
pâtisseries un décor hors du temps dans
ses salons de thé réputée dans le monde
entier
mais devant cette apparente quiétude les
regards des étrangers étaient remplis
d'inquiétude walter est un raciste
vraiment et il est très dangereux partie
des quatre coins cardinaux de la ville
la manifestation a pris la forme d'une
araignée géante police omniprésente mêlé
à une foule tranquille massés devant le
parlement
garder comme une véritable forteresse
humainement et à la tombée de la nuit
les autrichiens se sont pressés les uns
contres les autres sur helton plate la
place des héros ou en mars 1938 hitler
avait tenu un discours que personne ici
n'a oublié vienne retrouve sa mémoire
j'ai peur de venir aujourd'hui mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un signal qui
peuvent de nouveau chanter dans la rue
qu'ils ont des amis qui vont les protège
et qui montrent à leurs côtés et
d'ailleurs la meilleure chose qui arrive
aujourd'hui c'est que trois conseillers
municipaux des leaders ont décidé de
démissionner les manifestations
culturelles qui font gloire à rider il
faut les boycotter mais à la verse
il peut multiplier par boycotter les
gestes de solidarité
les passerelles les contacts avec la
vraie autriche tel quel à cette autriche
anti fasciste est en autriche anti
xénophobe cette autriche démocrate qui
se manifeste sous jouarre
difficile de faire un pas devant l'autre
pour que la capitale autrichienne
retrouve son visage paisible
il faudra du temps la résistance
s'organise et en direct de vienne
olivier lerner une manifestation donc
dans le calme dans les rues deviennent
aujourd'hui c'est un peu la majorité
silencieuse qui a qui a pris la parole
oui c'est vrai béatrice et la majorité
silencieuse qui commence à parler fort à
crier à exister en quelque sorte vous
savez le nouveau chancelier autrichien
wolfgang schüssel a demandé une période
de 100 jours de grâce avant de juger son
travail et bien on pense ici qu'il va
devoir affronter sans jour de colère il
y avait une drôle d'atmosphère
aujourd'hui dans vienne d'ordinaire si
paisible drôle d'atmosphère parce qu'il
ya maintenant deux camps qui
s'affrontent ouvertement il ya les pros
et les antis aïder le point positif
c'est que le débat est ouvert mais le
point négatif c'est que les étrangers et
souvent les juifs ou les homosexuels
sont prises à partie un turc à vienne
depuis cinq ans me disait tout à l'heure
qu'il avait été mal mené la majorité
silencieuse et bruyante ce soir elle se
fait entendre directement sous les
fenêtres de la chancellerie on peut dire
que le but des dizaines de milliers de
manifestants est atteint dernière
précision si vous permettez beatrice
d'york acbr n'était pas à vienne
aujourd'hui il assistait à une
compétition de vol à skis quelque part
en autriche
merci à lillers lerner en france dans
plusieurs grandes villes et au même
moment dans la capitale en écho au
rassemblement des manifestants anti
haider à vienne plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont défilé dans paris avec en
tête différentes personnalités
politiques
un cortège composé de citoyens d'europe
venus soutenir les autrichiens qui
défendent la démocratie c'est du moins
ce que l'on pouvait lire sur ces
banderoles déployées
je vis un berck jean pierre pasteur
le quartier de l'ambassade d'autriche
est totalement bouclé les manifestants
anti riders qui en ont fait la
destination de leur marche parisienne
n'irons pas plus loin et le ton monte
les esprits s'échauffent devant les
barrages installés par les crs le
discours lui et le même surtout qu'elle
est clair il a été aussi des élus
démocratiquement
alors la démocratie c'est pas ça la
démocratie c'est de savoir dire non et
non six répondre une réponse qu environ
dix mille personnes ont donc repris cet
après-midi dans les rues de la capitale
manifestation très politique presque
exclusivement à gauche des verts au
mouvement des citoyens en passant par
arlette l'aiguillé et même côté
socialiste par les deux prétendants à la
candidature pour la mairie de paris
jacques lang et bertrand delanoë
quant aux messages des politiques il se
voulait tout
la première pression elle est d'abord
sur le gouvernement autrichien pour que
il chasse les endroits et les données
sur les gouvernements européens sur
l'union européenne pour qu'elle soit
encore plus incisive et puis il ya ceux
qui considèrent qu'ils ont de bonnes
raisons de se trouver ici cet après-midi
pour manifester comme cette femme donc
pratiquement toute la famille a péri
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui nous savons ce qui peut
arriver à l'époque les matchs ne le
savaient pas de la même manière d'autres
raisons ce couple d'autrichiens qui vit
à paris voulait lui aussi être la
mobilisation finalement a été moins
forte que beaucoup l'espéraient certains
français il est vrai avait choisi
aujourd'hui d'aller manifester à vienne
pendant ce temps là au ministère de la
culture à l'initiative de catherine
trautmann plusieurs personnalités du
monde du cinéma et des arts débat tête
de la question de l'opportunité du
boycott de l'autriche fleurs muller jean
françois chauvet
comment dire non à jorg haider lorsqu'on
est un artiste au tour de catherine
trautmann
une trentaine d'intellectuels français
et autrichiens refusent la politique
d'extrême droite en autriche
on sait quel est le programme du parti
de monsieur haider qui au fond considère
qu'il faut avoir une seule langue
l'allemand qu'il faut opposer plutôt la
tradition et le régionalisme à la
création contemporaine
certains comme jane birkin viennent de
participer à la manifestation organisée
à paris cette réunion au ministère de la
culture a pour but d'élaborer un texte
commun à tous les artistes refusant la
politique de jörg haider mais le débat
d'aujourd'hui aiment vaut-il encore se
produire en outre un personnage est pas
être convaincu par la discussion qui va
suivre je pète peut-être pour effet de
contraire moi je pense qu'il faut pas y
aller moi je sais que finir tous les
artistes
si on est invité par exemple en autriche
il faut il faut aller là bas il faut
faire des conserves parce que je pense
que ceux qui ont voté front national
abbas c'est une minorité
le cinéaste autrichien michael haneke a
déjà subi les attaques de jörg haider
pourtant il met en garde ses confrères
contre le boycott ça peut aussi
provoquer une situation que un certain
nombre des autrichiens disent maintenant
tout tout tout le monde est contre nous
et se referme dans une accord avec avec
sept gouvernements et ce serait terrible
boycott ou pas tous les artistes
présents se disent prêts à inscrire leur
mouvement dans la durée
ce samedi marque et sur les routes de
france par le chassé croisé des trois
zones des vacances d'hiver les
prévisions de bison futé était
particulièrement pessimistes cette
journée fut mois noir que prévu avec
toutefois de gros bouchons vers la
montée des stations ce soir la situation
ensemble considérablement s'améliorer
didier guyot jean claude martin les les
bouchons ça t'énerve où tu les aimes
bien
pourquoi qu'on y est c'est vrai qu
aurore cinq ans a dû attendre et
patienter avec ses parents une à deux
heures de bouchon au péage d'albertville
deux à trois heures de trafic en
accordéon pour rejoindre moutier sans
oublier la pluie dans la vallée ces
centaines d'automobilistes qui sont à
vos côtés et plus haut la neige quelques
bonbons pour faire passer le temps ici
dans la vallée de la tarentaise on
bloque la circulation on régule pour ne
pas créer plus loin l'engorgement la
paralysie totale des axes routiers
mais qu'importe les automobilistes
prennent cela avec philosophie
et là c'est les vacances
donc il faut faire la queue voilà
effervescence au pc routier
d'albertville il faut absorber 32 mille
véhicules pour les départs et 24000 pour
les retours un va et vient incessant
avec ces mots dix automobilistes qui met
les chaînes alors qu'il n'y a pas de
neige chaînes sur soul of folk qui fait
ils bloquent toute circulation de ce qui
a été directement la conséquence
aujourd'hui savoir que sa noble que dax
pour beaucoup la journée fut longue
interminable et chaotique
une journée à oublier et ce sera vite
fait car demain c'est le ski et puis ces
recommandations de prudence pour ceux
qui tentent de faire du ski hors piste
une avalanche dans le nord de l'italie a
provoqué la mort d'un skieur deux autres
sont blessés dont l'un dans un état
grave
au chapitre social nouvelle mobilisation
contre le plan de restructuration chez
moulinex défilé dans les rues de caen
plusieurs milliers de personnes à
l'appel de différents syndicats et
associations
nous sommes des moulinex nous ne sommes
pas des kleenex parmi les slogans repris
par les salariés des différents sites
qui vous devez donc faire pression sur
le plan de restructuration annoncé fin
janvier par pierre blayau plan qui
prévoit la suppression de 1500 à 2000
emplois sur 18 mois lourdes de
protestation à bordeaux des
sylviculteurs plusieurs milliers de
manifestants faisant partie des métiers
du bois dans les rues du centre ville
pour protester contre la lenteur du
déblocage des aides de l'état après les
tempêtes de décembre dernier quand huit
femmes et vincent dubroca
des hommes des phares découragés qui ne
veulent pourtant pas baissé les bras
certains de ces civils culteurs ont tout
perdu ils espèrent les attendent mais ne
voit rien venir
les producteurs on parle pas d'eux et
tout les ailes sont pour le transport le
stockage les industriels et pour nous il
a rien d aide qui ne les concerne pas
des mesures qui se font attendre depuis
la tempête tous le disent il faut des
moyens pour gérer l'urgence
les aides annoncées pour le court terme
la mobilisation des bois sont
significatives mais le drame c'est
qu'elles ne sont toujours pas mises en
oeuvre
la déception la colère parfois ces
manifestants veulent être reconnus comme
des victimes
en aquitaine 28 millions de mètres cubes
de bois sont à terre l'équivalent de
plus de trois années de récolte à cette
catastrophe s'ajoute la chute des prix
nous sommes victimes aussi une politique
de prix qui est pratiqué parce qu'il ya
surabondance de l'offre certes
et puis il ya des comportements
d'acheteurs qui nous conviennent pas du
tout ce qui fait que nous avons nous
sommes doublement victime une perte
estimée à 4 milliards de francs en
aquitaine sans compter l'avenir il
faudra 30 à 50 ans pour reconstruire la
forêt nous évoquions hier dans notre
journal le cadre de cette famille
d'accueil jugées trop vieilles pour
continuer à aimer ses enfants de 5 et 7
ans placé par la dass depuis des années
aujourd'hui mobilisation d'amis de
parents d'élèves venus montrer leur
soutien ce couple de 65 et 61 ans il a
décidé à se battre pour conserver la
garde de pierre et de mickaël
apparemment les deux enfants ne seront
retirés que l'un dit à la famille qui
tentera de rencontrer les responsables
des services sociaux du département du
tarn
cette manifestation à paris quelques 250
personnes se sont retrouvées devant la
scala un ancien music hall de la
capitale pour protester contre
l'installation d'une secte pentecôtiste
d'origine brésilienne
il s'agit de l'église universelle du
royaume de dieu dont le nombre d'adeptes
en france elle a lieu entre 500 et 2000
selon le rapport parlementaire effectué
en 95 la mobilisation de tout un
arrondissement emmené par les élus
locaux
un mode politique avec ce sondage
ifop/journal du dimanche et les cotes de
popularité de jacques chirac comme celle
de lionel jospin sont en baisse ils
perdent chacun 4 points par rapport au
mois de janvier 56% des personnes
interrogées se disent satisfaites du
président de la république et 53% ont
une opinion favorable de lionel jospin
les premiers résultats des élections
législatives en iran confirme la nette
avancée des réformateurs dans les
régions rurales pourtant tenu par les
conservateurs même percée dans les
grandes villes comme ispahan ou massad
les résultats officiels concernant
notamment terran ne seront connus qu'en
début de semaine prochaine
mais d'ores et déjà il semble bien que
la société iranienne tourne
progressivement le dos au pouvoir des
religieux jean-marc il use jean françois
renaud
record battu 83,2 % de participation du
jamais vu en iran de quoi satisfaire
n'importe quel ministre de l'intérieur
surtout l'iranien monsieur moussavi un
proche du président réformiste mohammad
khatami
il sait
bien que forte participation c'est pain
béni pour les réformistes à téhéran des
indications recouper mais non officiel
donne ce soir
résa rate a mis en tête le jeune frère
du président un médecin de 40 ans a
réussi en quelques semaines a mobilisé
sur son nom les jeunes et les femmes
majoritaires en iran un revers
pratiquement consommer pour l'ex
président rafsandjani le porte parole de
la droite modérée dont les stratèges
conservateurs entendent toujours faire
le président d'un parlement dont il
semble devoir perdre le contrôle pour la
première fois depuis la révolution
islamique de 79 à téhéran la presse
pluraliste qui s'est malgré tout imposé
depuis trois ans faisait preuve d'une
rare unanimité pour célébrer le civisme
d'un électorat que la télévision
officielle n'avait guère préparés au
choix démocratique et même le chef des
conservateurs
ali khamenei le guide spirituel que la
constitution mais au dessus du président
a souligné qu'il fallait respecter le
suffrage populaire quel qu'il soit alors
même que les résultats officiels sont
loin d'être connu la pression ce soir à
téhéran
c'est qu'en iran le vent tourne après
deux retentissants échecs aux
présidentielles et aux municipales voilà
donc les conservateurs en passe de
perdre un troisième bastion le parlement
pour libérer l'état iranien de la
tutelle religieuse que lui impose la
constitution voilà donc aussi le
président khatami mieux armé pour
l'emporter dans cette nouvelle bataille
qui commence au kosovo après deux
semaines d'affrontements sporadiques à
mitrovica entre communautés serbe et
albanaise madeleine albright qualifie d'
de tragédies la situation dans cette
région où de très vives tensions rendent
improbable tout espoir d'apaisement nous
envier spéciaux à nous consignes et
gilles jacquier ont enquêté sur ces
actes de violence qui se sont produits
la semaine passée parfaite illustration
des difficultés que rencontre la kfor
pour imposer un semblant de paix
enquête sur la fusillade de dimanche
dernier à mitrovica de policiers des
nations unies faisait ce matin les
constatations d'usagé
objectif savoir si les violences à
mitrovica sont organisés et parlant au
cours des affrontements deux soldats
français ont été gravement blessés la
kfor estime que les agresseurs étaient
albanais et que l'un d'entre eux a été
touché au contraire les habitants du
quartier eux n'ont vu aucun albanais en
armes ce jour là une chose est sûre
lorsqu après des heures d'affrontements
les français ont encerclé des hommes
il n'avait rien contre eux il y avait
plus d'armes plus rien mais ils ont eu
largement le temps avant qu'on arrive de
cacher les armes et les blessés et 2 a
bien sûr nous nous n'avons absolument
pris en compte aucun blessé nous n'avons
vu aucun un homme est arrivé blessé par
balle à l'hôpital ce jour là il est mort
peu après avni haredi ni ses proches
viennent faire leurs condoléances dans
son café ces jours ci à venir est
fortement soupçonné d'être un tireur
isolé
c'est vrai qu'il fut combattants de
loucher cas mais son frère d'armes dit
qu'il n'avait plus rien à voir avec tout
ça
on est revenus à venir et moi je ne peux
parler que pour nous nous n'avons plus
aucun contact avec lui et c'est comme ça
depuis que l'accord de paix signé
bajrami explique que son ami ne faisait
pas le coup de feu contre la kfor
dimanche selon lui à venir a été tué
alors qu'il venait de franchir l'eau en
direction du nord de mitrovica pour
sauver des femmes et des enfants
albanais avoir les armes de guerre s'est
dit hier à mitrovica chez les serbes
comme chez les albanais il est clair que
la kfor est en ligne de mire
avni était-il un tireur isolé l'autopsié
de son corps permettrait peut-être d'en
savoir plus mais elle n'a pas été fait
d'ailleurs aucune enquête de police mais
encore ouverte sur sa mort ce n'est
certainement pas ce rythme qu'on peut
répondre à l'urgence de mitrovica
le président égyptien hosni moubarak a
passé quelques heures aujourd'hui à
beyrouth il s'agit de la première visite
d'un chef d'état égyptien au liban une
visite éclair perçue comme un geste de
soutien après les raids israéliens qui
ont touché le liban il ya dix jours pour
le gouvernement libanais il s'agit d'une
condamnation d'israël
hosni moubarak au terme d'un entretien
avec le président libanais appelle à une
reprise des négociations de paix
l'événement sportif la rencontre choc
entre le quinze de france et
l'angleterre au stade de france cet
après midi les tricolores ont trébuché
la rose avait des épines l'angleterre
l'emporter 15 à 9 lors de la 2e journée
du tournoi des six nations les français
se disent ce soir déçu par l'arbitrage
christophe duchiron laurent chemla
après 25 minutes de jeu les bleus sont
venus 6 à 0 2 pénalités de l'anglais
wilkinson et voilà christophe dominici
qui fait son festival
il s'arrache à la défense des blancs la
balle au cordeau pour thomas lombard qui
va aplatir
la france revient au score et
normalement on va voir ce qu'on va voir
ce que l'on va vite comprendre c'est que
l'arbitré australien refuse décès en
raison d'un en avant que l'on qualifiera
de discutables indéniablement ce
monsieur dickinson à la sûreté dans ce
jugement et sûrement 10 sur 10 h accueil
un peu plus tard olivier brouzet expulsé
pendant 10 minutes pour antijeu la
pénalité qui suit est réussi car
wilkinson à la pause 9 à 0 pour les
anglais et c'est logique car les anglais
ont dominé la première période avec du
rythme et du physique
les optimistes pensent donc impossible
n'est pas français les pessimistes hall
berenberg
et le regard inquiet à la reprise les
bleus refont surface et rivalise
physiquement avec l'adversaire résultat
deux pénalités entre les barques de
charlesbourg 9 à 6 au score pour
l'angleterre mais les plans ne dure pas
assez longtemps et les anglais répondent
de nouvelle pénalité de wilkinson 15 à 6
fischer à 9 quand richard d'autres aiguë
le score peu après nous jouons
maintenant les dernières secondes du
match les anglais jouent à 13 si les
bleus marque et transforme en essayent
l'emportent d'un point pénalité jouée à
la main par le tricolore
et tous les supporters du xiii de france
qui crient pendant tes autres poussent
la marée bleue dans l'en but adverse
mais il n'y aura pas et c'est l'arbitré
a raison un anglais empêcher un français
d'aplatir
adieu veaux vaches victoire les anglais
plus forts méritent leur succès un match
un match de rugby avait avec un
engagement avec du combat et bon ben
voilà malheureusement s'est mal terminée
pour
je crois qu'on me fait un match on n'est
pas bon dans la gestion du jeu en
première mi-temps et puis on retrouve
quelques valeurs en deuxième mi temps où
on ne peut effectivement peut-être
importés mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce
dont je pensais être la meilleure équipe
du nombre s'est avéré vrai je crois
qu'il faut les féliciter
nettement moins tragique que waterloo
c'était quand même saint-denis mort de
plaine certes le quinze de la rose en
impose mais si les bleus ont perdu une
bataille
ils m'ont pas encore perdu la guerre
mais on imagine aisément l'ambiance
euphorique qui régnait de l'autre côté
de la manche dans les pubs anglais où
les supporteurs ont regardé leur équipe
gagner presque dans un fauteuil
maryse burgot chanter un bassin
si way
cet après midi dans ce pub de londres on
sentait très clairement que ces anglais
un brin tendus avait bien l'intention de
nous battre nous les français
soit ils la tiennent leur revanche
contre ce quinze de france qui a eu la
prétention de finir demi finaliste lors
de la coupe du monde les anglais ils
sont capable d'autocritique alors que
les français c'est bien connu sont très
prétentieux maintenant il est important
que les anglais reprennent confiance en
eux mêmes c'est sûrement l'un des
matches les plus effrayants de ces
dernières années c'était bien vraiment
bien aurait tellement bien que pendant
le match on n'avait pas intérêt à les
déranger et à la mi temps ils se
contentent de nous quand des deux mots
british beat c'est à dire le boeuf
anglais l'autre bataille contre les
britanniques mais cette fois sur le
front de la vache folle
et à la fin du match il n'en finissent
pas de porter la bonne nouvelle
là je suis devant la télévision
française c'est tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que c'est la meilleure équipe qui
a gagné en angleterre un duel ancestrale
qui cette fois ci nie bien pour les
anglais mais comme d'habitude il y aura
un jour une revanche aujourd'hui pour
cette deuxième journée du tournoi des
six nations le pays de galles a battu
l'italie 47 à 16 au stade du millénaire
à cardiff de son côté l'irlande s'est
imposée face à l'ecosse 44 à 22 après à
vendre laetitia masson s'offre johnny
hallyday dans son nouveau film love me
qui sort mercredi prochain le chanteur
passionné de cinéma prouve une fois
encore par ses choix qu'il aime le
cinéma d'auteur parce qu'elle deschamps
alain dupas
les gueules le film quand on en prend on
entend vraiment vers l'intérieur
c'était bien parce que c'était le rôle
d'un chanteur ne s'était pas rôle d'un
chanteur s'était pas johnny hallyday
impossible de raconter novices et mais
moi aime moi comme un cri tout se passe
dans la tête de gabriel jeunes chômeuses
que leur ai fait vivre sur l'écran noir
de ces nuits blanches elle s'invente une
idylle avec son idole lennox rancoeur
france est revenu tout un vrai défi
comme l'acteur à l'idée les aime qui
survit qui servait pour jouer au jeu
pour pour vivre tout simplement pour
vivre ou revivre tous les jours on vit
dans les hôtels pour ce faire des copies
pour pourvoir y croit plus en l'amour
c'est tout le contraire de vue moi j'y
crois parce que le mot grâce à dieu
quand est ce que vous allez comprendre
comment être pas mon genre paraît trop
c'est trop
j'aime pas vote mais j'aime pas de
bouche aux yeux aux cheveux j'aime pas
votre cas
j'aimerais r c'est un cinéma intelligent
pas facile pour peut-être pour tout le
monde mais en tout cas rater les gens
est intéressant moi je sais que je ne
serai pas dans le film j'irai le voir
j'ai valoir canton le plaisir que j'ai
été voir à vendre et et où j'ai été
fable d'avant dont il se bat de nice
remet en question c'est bien pour ça
d'ailleurs que qu'on s'en lasse pas et
que lui-même ne se lasse pas de ce qui
fait il et nous l'a prouvé leur faisant
le film avec nous il fait mis en danger
constamment et là ils jouaient le jeu
dès le début mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
vraiment qui est loin d'avoir fini son
parcours ce qui va nous surprendre
encore l'homme lui c'est une heure
cinquante d'émotion pure sur les traces
de deux écorchés
une rencontre pas banale entre ceux qui
rêvent et ceux qui les font rêver mais
c'est parti la même solitude
et puis cette dernière information avant
de refermer cette édition on apprend à
l'instant le verdict de la cour
d'assises de seine-maritime dans la
sphère jean yves morel laborantins de 35
ans reconnu coupable du meurtre de deux
jeunes femmes et du viol de l'une
d'elles a été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
c'est donc la fin de ce journal nous en
rappelle les principaux titres alerte à
la listériose 19 départements touchés 23
cas recensés une épidémie qui a fait
sept morts dont deux nouveaux nés
l'origine est pour l'instant inconnue
jean glavany nice de l'agriculture qui
était l'invité de ce journal évoque une
épidémie en décrue rugby les tricolores
trébuche au stade de france l'angleterre
s'est imposée 15 à 9 pour cette deuxième
journée du tournoi des six nations les
français se disent déçus par l'arbitrage
dans un instant la météo patrice drevet
20h55 une nuit magique couvrant enfants
animé par catherine la rider alain
souchon lara fabian saisi l'équipe de
notre dame de paris bien d'autres
participeront à cette soirée
exceptionnelle
23h25 tout le monde en parle présentée
par thierry ardisson 1h30 le dernier
journal en compagnie de thierry
thuillier de ma dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra et perd escale
à l'occasion de la sortie de son dernier
film le guinée j'aurais quant à moi le
plaisir de vous retrouver de mal dès 13h
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2 à
demain
tous